hi everyone welcome welcome to the
interval my name is Michel Micheli with
the long now foundation we're so happy
to welcome you here to our San Francisco
headquarters the interval I knew Tim's
name before you know I I knew I knew
what he looked like or anything from his
publishing endeavors and you know just I
just wanted to sort of set the tone that
you know in in the early 90s on the
other side of the coast on the East
Coast you know the William Gibson saying
is that the the futures already here
it's not evenly distributed as those of
us that live in the Bay Area know San
Francisco is a place that the future
clumps up and it doesn't get to the
middle or the other side of the country
or other countries it takes a while to
to do there to get there and in the
early 90s pre-web or the very early days
of the web
there were channels that we would we
would hear these little broadcasts the
future Wired magazine mondo the whole
earth of course before before that and
then these books started showing up on
some of my geekier friends desks with
these compelling animal figures on them
and this was another really important
message from the future really as new
important technologies were coming out
they were being documented and you know
O'Reilly media was like the record label
of these emerging technologies getting
released on a regular basis I wasn't
reading most of them I was the English
major of the the geeky set so but but
clearly something was going on there and
when you get to San Francisco it all
starts to make more sense of it maybe
but so just to say that tim has been
looking for patterns and and charting
the territory of the
the terrier we're about to reach for a
long time
and with this new book he's both looking
back and looking forward for us and he's
going to share some I think really
compelling stuff now so give it a big
round of applause for Tim thanks very
much for having me it's kind of
wonderful to speak with a small group
and a little bit informally I am gonna
use some slides but I'm also going to do
a reading from the book which I have not
done before Michael asked if I would do
that and I thought it would be fun to do
it to read you a couple of passages and
in some ways I've used the slides to cue
up the passages so the other thing that
really shaped this talk is this
illustration which I will come to I
wasn't planning I was planning a very
different talk and then when we decided
to do this illustration I said well it
has to be about the part of the book
that relates to the illustration even
though the illustration does not appear
in the book it deeply shaped my life and
my thinking and I'm gonna tell you a
little bit of the backstory of that in
order to make that clear so I actually
have you know sort of frame this not
just about the book but in particularly
about a part of the book which is about
how to think about the future and it's
rooted in the idea that the way we talk
about things is actually our map of the
world and just as physical maps can be
wrong the way we talk about the world
can lead us astray and a lot of what
I've done throughout my career in
technology has been to look at the maps
we're using and say oh oh it's leaving
out these things and to try to tell a
different story than what other people
were telling and so you know back in the
you know early days of the free software
movement
I was like why aren't you guys talking
about the Internet why are you just
talking about Linux you know and it was
just there was this this map that was
the political story about free software
that overwhelmed looking at the entire
world and saying well well there's all
these really interesting free software
programs and some of them are actually
even more successful than Linux and why
we have to have a story that explains
all of them and that's what led me to
you know do the activism that I did
about open source software and similarly
after the dot-com bust we were able to
say well there's a lot of companies that
survive well
distinguish them and how do we tell the
story about what that was and that was
the web 2.0 movement but what I've been
focused on you know over the last four
or five years has been thinking about
technology and the economy and in
particular you know I've been thinking
about what the great technology
platforms of today teach us about
business and the future of the economy
because it seems to me that you know
Google and Amazon and Facebook in some
ways our economies themselves and their
rise and their fall their successes and
their failures and the techniques that
they're using to manage their economies
actually teach us a lot about the
economy as a whole
they also teach us something about the
rise of a new kind of platform
capitalism where we're building these
platforms that aggregate work in new
ways that aggregate demand in new ways
that are very different than the old
markets of supply and demand coordinated
by price alone you know think for
example about Google's ad auction they
they came up with other signals besides
besides price that actually said no no
this is the best ad you know there's a
lot of really interesting stuff
happening in the world of tech but I was
really focused in particular on you know
how when they become extractive they
tend to fail but that's not what I'm
going to talk about
because of this diagram what I'm really
going to talk about is the the first
part of the book which really explains a
lot of the techniques that I've tried to
use to build stories to tell stories to
see the world and in some sense to draw
the maps that I then worked from and I
also want to talk a little bit about how
to make better choices but let me start
really with this sort of notion of the
entrepreneur as the Explorer
you know we guys we've all been pretty
excited recently to see at least if
you're like me you know you grow you
know with this science fiction vision of
spaceships that you know Rockets took
often and they landed and then you know
you know but we we had lived for 40
years where they took off and they just
dropped in the ocean with a parachute
what was wrong with that picture and
suddenly you know we're doing it and
technology changed but it's also the the
willingness to think a little bit
differently
similarly 2005 you know we had connected
taxicabs and they looked like that like
we knew what you did with the internet
you put a screen you know somewhere and
you showed ads and you showed news
so 2005 the connected taxicab was the
Internet in the back of the taxi cab
right now we're having this idea that
you know robots are gonna put everybody
how to work and yet the evidence is that
this is wrong but bad maps persist you
know back in 1625 there was a map done
of California that showed it as an
island and that map persisted as the
accepted knowledge the wisdom there
actually were expeditions that took
boats to the Mojave Desert because there
was this great passage the the gulf of
you know I mean the Sea of Cortez went
all the way up to Canada all right no it
didn't but we had a map that persisted
for a hundred years that told people
that that was true and that's really you
know what happened here was Elon Musk
the map you know Jeff Bezos is working
also rewriting the map you know we
really came to understand that the
connected taxi cab was not a screen in
the back of the cab it was this new you
know combination of humans and machines
into this vast network you know where
people are being dispatched by algorithm
it's this incredible rethinking of the
capabilities that are given to us by the
smartphone with sensors where all of a
sudden you know where everybody is and
you go wow we can do coordination at
scale in a very different way and so
there was this new rediscovery that's
rethinking this rewriting of the map
that took us from that 2005 we're gonna
show you ads in the back of the taxi cab
to well you can just pull out your phone
and summon the car to wherever you are
and there'll be this swarming mass of
drivers more of them when when you need
them fewer than when you don't you know
a lot to work out still but boy we're
rewriting that map big time similarly on
the robots and jobs you know here's
here's Amazon 2014 to 2016
put 45,000 robots into their warehouses
and hired 250,000 people you know yeah
we're still talking about the robots are
gonna take all our jobs I just had a
conversation this morning with Hal
Varian Google's chief economist and he
has to talk he's working out which he
calls a BOTS and tots and it's basically
about this idea of robots and jobs and
he's like look the one thing we know for
sure he said there's only one social
science that can predict the future and
its demographics yeah and we actually
look at demographics and the supply of
labor is going to be going down down
down in the absence of immigration you
know so we're actually not running out
of jobs we're running out of workers you
know and yet the bad map persists and
you we also have the example of someone
like Amazon saying no no we actually
gonna yeah we're not gonna do the same
thing more cheaply with robots we're
gonna start delivering
same-day you know and of course then
they put loss
the people to work so rewriting the map
is the central entrepreneurial act but
it's also something that we have to do
for our society and that's really the
polemic part of the book because I'm
really trying to get people thinking
about what do we have to do to redraw
the map in such a way that we don't just
do it the way we've always done it
there's so many possibilities you know
if in fact the robots could do more of
the work why do we have to organize
society the same way and I want to come
to that back to that a little bit later
so may a great entrepreneur see the
world with fresh eyes and they get out
of a certain kind of framing blindness
that's so often you know gets us kind of
just seeing the world the way that we
always accepted it so now we come to
this diagram this is a drawing from a
kind of crazy book from the 1920s called
a science and sanity by Alfred Korzybski
and it's called the structural
differential he actually patented it was
a training device to help you understand
something that he wrote in science and
sanity that the map is not the territory
so the idea of it is this is yeah
actually I made one arrive as a teenager
you know after reading the book you know
and you're supposed to basically as
you've talked as you thought you're
supposed to finger this device to
understand where you were in the process
of abstraction because what it is is a
diagram of the process by which we turn
the stuff of reality into the stuff
inside our head so the idea was that big
thing at the top was a representation of
a parabola that is reality is infinite
you know there's just so much there the
circle represents the experience of an
individual human of that infinite
reality that we're all looking at and
the strings that come from the infinite
reality to the individual experience
represent the fact that we abstract only
part of what we see of what we hear
right and so for example
and they and and the fact of this
multiple circles indicates that each of
us doesn't even experience the same
thing and it's even a small it's as
small as the fact that one person is
looking at me from over there someone
else is looking at me from over there
but it also could be that we have
different visual acuity that anybody in
the room is colorblind no but there are
people who are you know this awk you
know so you would see my shirt
differently so this whole idea that
there's this big difference between the
reality and the experience of it and
then you get into the labeling the
abstraction and course lipski's point in
science and sanity is there's so many
places where we go wrong because we get
stuck in the labels and you actually
think with labels that's why we do it
you know we we have these abstractions
which are these convenient ways for us
not to have to notice anymore you know
and so his idea here was this device you
would look at it and you go okay well I
I'm actually you know I I'm not actually
looking at the thing I'm just using the
convenient word for it so let me go back
and look at it and there was that so
anyway I got into all this as a result
of some work I did in the 70s in San
Francisco growing up with a guy named
George Simon who was using it as a sort
of a gateway drug to nonverbal
communication and sort of expanded
perception and really amazing you can
actually train yourself to notice where
you are are you actually looking are you
actually taking in you can yeah how
could I sit with something and take in
more of it you know connect more of
those strings and they sort of an
experiential practice just like you have
meditation but I don't want to spend a
lot of time on that what I want to
really talk about a little bit is again
Maps okay here we are Fort Mason oh wait
here we are Fort Mason you know here we
are Fort Mason wait a minute
something a little odd about this map
right because if you're like me you and
you think about the Bay Area from
distance you think about it like that
don't you you know
because we're so used to that
north-south orientation that we actually
think it's part of the reality we don't
realize that that north-south
orientation is something that happens
down here right and there's a lot of
things like that in our experience and
if we go back you know and you go wow
what else do you see when you actually
look at it a little bit differently you
know like one of the things I found
really interesting when I the reason I
chose this I like I tend to think saris
Cove goes north south and you don't
really notice because of that sort of
filter blindness that the north-south
orientation of San Francisco is actually
not echoed by a north-south orientation
in Marin Marin goes way out to the west
you know and so but but as soon as you
sorry you go to the yeah you flip the
orientation you can really see wow it's
not straight up and down at all it's
just so that kind of filter blindness
there's a lot of exercises you can do to
train yourself to go oh look anyway so
the thing that's really critical is you
know you know noticing what's left out
of the map you know and you know for me
a lot of that was there was a map of
innovation that was about you know
venture capitalists and entrepreneurs
and I had a map that said no no I
actually look at these weird alpha geeks
as I call the people who were just doing
technology for fun and how do you what
are they interested in you know so back
when everybody thought all the money was
to be made in you know in on the PC you
know these people who were going well is
this thing with the Internet this thing
was open-source software so we have
these sort of periods where we can learn
by looking at different kinds of people
but also you know wanted to talk about
another way that you can kind of catch
the future and that's where the metaphor
you know there's this wonderful thing
that poets do which is that they help us
to express the inexpressible and to
capture things that we don't yet fully
understand
you know when we're back in this diagram
they help us say well yeah this this
thing that's infinite you know as blake
said if the doors of perception were
cleansed everyone would see things as
they are infinite or see reality as it
is infinite you know you know we're
stuck in this tiny selection from what's
what's really there and poetry can be a
wonderful way of pointing to that so
anyway I actually was very happy to be
able to put a little bit of poetry in my
book because I it's to me it's something
I truly love but anyway so I'm talking
in this particular passage the book just
to be clear is it's a combination of a
memoir a business book and a sort of
economic call to action you know a
polemic if you like about what we need
to do differently but I was talking a
little bit about this history by which I
went from describing the Internet as an
operating system you know the people
again it was it was now really kind of
gets at your cloud computing and so on
but it was this new idea the time to
actually using a metaphor of the
Internet as the global brain in fact I
did a talk for long now called towards a
global brain she's about that but here's
a story on page 41 the notion of the
Internet as an operating system for the
next generation of applications had
taken me a long way by 2010 the idea but
I started talking about that in about
2000 so it was about nine years of
pushing that by 2010 the idea had taken
hold in the industry developers were
routinely writing applications that
relied on data from Internet services
about location search results social
networks music products and so much more
startups were no longer building local
applications in their own data centers
but rather was now called the cloud I
didn't need to keep preaching that gap
gospel and frankly I was ready to move
on as TS Eliot so memorably put it one
has only learned to get the better of
words for the thing one no long
has to say or the way in which one is no
longer disposed to say it and so each
venture is a new beginning a raid on the
inarticulate actually I wanted to read
you a little bit more than that from
that wonderful passage from East Coker
which I beyond right I put it in the
book to pastors just for cons he says
there there is it seems to us at best
only a limited value in the knowledge
derived from experience the knowledge
imposes a pattern and falsifies for the
pattern is new in every moment and every
moment is a new and shocking valuation
of all we have been we are only
undeceived of that which deceiving could
no longer harm so here I am in the
middle way
having had twenty years twenty years
largely wasted trying to use words and
every attempt is a wholly new start and
a different kind of failure this is
where I pick up the piece in the book
because one has only learnt to get the
better of words for the thing one no
longer has to say or the way in which
one is no longer disposed to say it and
so each venture is a new beginning our
raid on the inarticulate with shabby
equipment always deteriorating in the
general mess of imprecision of feeling
on the undisciplined squads of emotion
and of course but that is what you know
poetry does is actually to give you this
wonderful set of images so I had started
to use this image of the global brain
and and I kind of particularly focused
on it with with Twitter but anyway I
also finished reading this before I
before I move on so increasingly I've
been watching a kind of Cambrian
explosion in applications for collective
intelligence they were qualitatively
different from those to the desktop web
smartphones that put a camera in
everyone's hand and Twitter had created
a real-time platform from which
photos and text updates could be
instantly disseminated to the world
billions of connected humans and devices
were being woven into a global brain
that brain was all of us augmented and
connected and then later on in the book
I pick up this this thread again and and
and and this is where I'm talking about
AI I say when we imagine an artificial
intelligence we assume it will have an
individual self an individual
consciousness just like us and this is
one of our Maps our implicit Maps what
if instead an AI were more like a
multicellular organism an evolution
beyond our single-celled cells what's
more what if we were not even the cells
of such an organism but it's microbiome
the vast ecology of microorganisms that
inhabits our bodies this notion is at
best a metaphor but I believe it is a
useful one as the internet speeds up the
connection between human minds as our
collected knowledge memory and
sensations are shared and stored in
digital form we are weaving a new kind
of technology mediated superorganism a
global brain consisting of all connected
humans this global brain is a human
machine hybrid the senses of that global
brain are the cameras microphones
keyboards and location senses of every
computer smartphone and Internet of
Things device the thoughts of that
global brain or the collective output of
billions of individual contributing
intelligences shaped guided and
amplified by algorithms digital services
like Google Facebook and Twitter that
connect hundreds of millions or even
billions of people in near-real-time are
already primitive hybrid ai's the fact
of the intelligence of these systems is
interdependent with the intelligence of
the community of humans that make it up
is an echo of the way that we ourselves
function each of us is a vast nation of
trillions of differentiated cells only
some of which share our own DNA DNA
while far more are immigrants the vast
microbiome of microorganisms that Colin
our guts our skin our circulatory
systems they're far more microorganisms
in our bodies than there are human cells
not invaders but a functioning part of
the whole without the microorganisms we
host we could not digest our food or
turn it into useful energy the bacteria
in our guts have even been shown to
change how we think and how we feel a
multicellular organism is the sum of the
communications the ecosystem the
platform or marketplace if you will of
all its participants and when that
marketplace gets out of balance we fall
ill or fail to live up to our potential
humans are living in the guts of an AI
that is only now being born perhaps like
us the global AI will not be an
independent entity but a symbiosis with
the human consciousness is living within
it and alongside it so I kind of go from
there to thinking about how this applies
to our algorithmic systems and how
they're changing the nature of the
relationship between humans and machines
and and how they're changing the nature
of our financial markets so I'm not
going to spend a lot of time on that but
just there's lots about that in the book
but I want to kind of move on to
continue to talk about this how you know
what tools can use to think about the
future and I just I look all the time
somebody says something it helps me see
the world in a new way
you know Michael earlier quoted William
Gibson's wonderful quote the future is
here it's just not evenly distributed
yeah now I'm not sure I actually really
I correctly take credit for it I read
that in a magazine somewhere and I think
I'm the person who made that famous
because I used it so many for so many
years in so many speeches you know it
was just something I picked up out of a
magazine because it's like yeah that's
true you know and I think about these
other ones Edmund schlossberg said yeah
the skill of writing is to create a
context in which other people can think
you know Ray Kurzweil once said an
invention has to make sense in the world
news and which is finished not the world
in which it started these are like
incredible tools you know like somebody
says something you know you go wow yeah
I'm gonna look for
I'm gonna see it it's just like this
little lens you know because that's the
thing that you can do you can pick up
this little label and then you can kind
of use it to kind of go back up the
chain and see now there's one that I
just you know one of the things that
Michael asked me to do is to talk about
stuff that's not in the book but that's
like the continuation and here's one of
the things as is my next slide this is a
wonderful book called the divine right
of capital which is not in the book
because I didn't know about it but I
actually used a metaphor late in the
book I wrote you know you know future
economic historians will look back you
know wryly on this period in which
something like I should have found I
found in the book and read it we look
back Riley on this period in which we
look down on our ancestors for believing
in the Divine Right of Kings while we
believe in the divine right of capital
and so one of my readers sent me an
email saying you know are you familiar
with Margery Kelly's book the divine
right of capital and one of the things
that she wrote in their wish I just
never really even thought about it just
took for granted she said look our
financial statements tell us how to
think about you know relationship
between businesses and their workers
encoded in financial statements notice
we kind of go okay yeah the profit is
the revenue minus the costs all right
but then that got restated somehow that
that's actually capital income revenue
minus employee income because actually
the income to a business is employee is
is income to the people who work there
and the people who made investments but
we ended up defining the bottom line as
the return to capital Jesus look you
could just as easily say there is a way
that you organize businesses where the
return you know the bottom line is the
return to their workers and capital is
an input that you consider a cost and it
was just such a really interesting kind
of reframing of the map that's embodied
in our financial statements that we
again going back to this we take a
financial statement as somehow a
representation of reality when in fact
it's a particular description you know
and she kind of goes in at length about
the Divine Right of Kings you know where
for you know it's really you know for a
thousand years there was this idea that
certain people were closer to God and
they actually as a result of being
closer to God they own more stuff and
they were supposed to own more stuff and
she kind of goes off on this wonderful
thing about that you know this book of
the peerage you know we're sort of like
literally the hierarchy of people in the
universe and who deserves the most you
know it's like and he goes from the king
and then there's the Prince of Wales and
then there's you know on down through
all the you know down to the lower
barons and then there's the ordinary
people and and sort of interesting she's
well now we have you know the Forbes 400
whatever yeah and it's a really
interesting just little example of
somebody throwing out an idea and then
you go wow yeah I could see the world in
a whole new way so let me do a time here
I think I'm running a little long so the
other thing that I found really useful
as a tool for thinking about the future
is to think in vectors you know vector
is you know basically a quantity and a
direction and you know so in in terms of
our so experience or thinking about the
future
take demographics you know this is a
direction and a quantity they're going
to be we know that there are more people
being born
growing up in different countries you
know demographics is destiny this is a
vector they're Moore's Law for many
years was a knowable vector and you can
start to think about these things and
start to theorize about the future based
on a map that's really not a map of what
is but a map of here's what we know
about the present that might tell us
something about the future and of course
there's a discipline and here Lawrence
is sitting right in the front and
Stuart's deeply in their discipline that
was you know design specifically around
this idea of how do you use vectors as a
way of thinking about possible
influences on the future and then
actually start to theorize about what
that might be and in the book actually
do a just as a way of introducing
scenario planning which of which I wrote
about by shamelessly you know ripping
off Lawrence's a you know explication of
it to me when he did us so now your
planning exercise with my company many
years ago but I I kind of you know you
can kind of understand you know if we
think about climate change this is a
possibility that you know there's not
much to it you know the Republicans
certainly don't think there is right so
let's just assume that that's a real
possibility and over there you know but
then there's also the possibility that's
like holy [ __ ] it's really bad you know
and then there's the how do we respond
that's also a vector we get we're gonna
possibly respond very slowly we're gonna
spot very fast and then you kind of you
build this a bunch of scenarios and you
say okay well if the problem is fast and
big and the response is fast and big you
know this is a possibility technology
saves the day this is the Silicon Valley
narrative right this also the problem is
non-existent what happens well actually
Elon Musk is still doing pretty well
because we all like our electric cars
even if we it was no climate change so
that's your innovation premium scenario
right and you know on the other hand we
don't do anything there's no no problem
we got business as usual not terribly
interesting not a lot of opportunity on
the other hand we have slow non-existent
response than a big problem oh my god
societal will collapse
really bad news right so the key concept
of scenario planning is that you're
looking for a robust strategy that is
something that you would want to do in
any circumstance and of course this
reminds me of Pascal's wager which was
you know the mathematician Blaise Pascal
who basically made an argument for why
it's better to believe in God even if
you don't know whether it's true
this was the medieval not medieval but
you know Renaissance version but this is
the 21st century equivalent you know it
makes sense to deal with climate change
so I did a similar exercise then for
what I'm calling you know AI robots in
the next economy you know sort of like
we have this possibility of machines
doing all the work or or actually
machines actually being enablers for new
kinds of work which is of course we're
always happened before you know we
didn't actually just do the same thing
as we got to do new things you know we
didn't used to fly through the air you
know and then magically we get to fly
through the air you know so and that
created tourism at a different scale and
so on so and then there's this other
vector which is optimizing for just the
owners of the machines or optimizing for
everyone and again the question that I
ask and I try to address in the book is
what is the robust strategy and the
robust strategy is I love this quote the
people will rise up before the machines
do which is what happens if we basically
machines do all the work and the the
owners of the machines get all the
benefit is as Andy McAfee said to me the
people will rise up before the robots do
but there's also you also have the
situation even when there's magical new
kinds of work if we optimize only for
the owners of the machines we end up
going while we're all getting screwed
you know it's like it's the world is
amazing but we're not getting the
benefit of it and to me what I call the
WTF of astonishment is we're continuing
you know hey oh my god we're bringing
extinct species back to life right you
know isn't this awesome and we're using
it to rebuild the world you know we're
helping ourselves to adapt to climate
change for example
that's the WTF of astonishment where
we're optimizing for everyone and where
technology is enabling new kinds of work
but you know hey you know even if the
machines do all the work there's a
future of creative abundance where this
everybody's hanging out of places like
the interval right so anyway I kind of
go so the robust strategy pretty clearly
is optimized for everyone and
and I think I actually think enabling
new kinds of work is in fact the really
interesting you know robust future so I
think I'm gonna stop there I have a
bunch of other you know parts of where
I've kind of unpacked some of the maps
that I kind of try to describe in the
book but I'd like to have time to
interact with all of you yeah thanks hey
mebu ground of applause for Tim
so think of think of your questions
Rio's going to be walking around with a
mic Tim I got a couple things to get you
started this is great and the book is
wonderful what's really interesting an
interesting aspect of the book you can
really see the textbook writer in you
because there are these little call-outs
periodically and and and like it really
just as you were telling us about
wanting to communicate how to think
about the future now to read the future
it's not someone who's just saying this
is the way it's going to be you're
giving your analysis but you're also
giving little tips there they're just
literally these call-outs
simple decentralized systems work better
at generating new possibilities than
centralized complex systems because
they're able to evolve more quickly
each decentralized component within the
overall framework of simple rules is
able to seek out its own fitness
function those components that work
better reproduce and spread those that
don't die off and and and so it's really
this trajectory that dates back you know
to and and you know the textbook
industry it seems is something you got
into really kind of accidentally but it
seems like can you say something about
you and I guess it fits with the mission
of the company as well how you think
about technology and enabling other
people that the teaching of it the the
work that you do in terms of sharing not
just what's going on but how to the
maker aspect really of everything you
know very early on I asked myself you
know what do we really do at my company
so just so you understand O'Reilly Media
started out as a tech writing consulting
firm then we became a computer book
publisher then we started running
technology conferences we started an
online ebook platform which evolved into
an online learning platform which is
really the heart of the business today
but we realized actually in some work
that we did with with with Lawrence the
Lawrence Wilkinson is sitting here in
the front row
you know we really
started asking ourselves a lot about who
we want to be overall and in this sort
of period of investigation we really
started to think of ourselves as a
technology transfer company at heart
that our business was fundamentally
changing the world by spreading the
knowledge of innovators and we've tried
to you know live by that ever since and
our you know are sort of our motto what
the company is create more value than
you capture which came out of a
management retreat again about that time
about 2000 when I was telling the story
to my executive team of an internet
billionaire who will remain nameless
who'd said he'd started his company with
an O'Reilly book and I said yes great
you know he got billions and we got 30
bucks seems like a good trade you know
because we really like using the service
that he built you know it's like you
know we got 30 bucks but we also got
this amazing you know service so well
anyway then Brian Irwin who is my VP of
Marketing said yeah we create more value
than we capture and then we started
making that as a a motto something that
I often think about O'Reilly and there's
some other organizations like this but
you know that we have the the old story
about the original California Gold Rush
that the ones that really got rich were
the people that were selling picks and
shovels and you were in a way selling
picks and shovels and it's not that you
got richer but you're still here and
you're continuing to adapt and some of
those people had they're doing well and
not doing much and enjoying themselves
but but it's not the but but it's it's
it's both a solid business it's also
continuing to ride the wave of what's
coming next yeah I mean I think there's
a major element in the book it's really
shifted we have a early-stage venture
firm which is really focused on this I
really started to understand and again
one of the chapters in the book is is
called super money and it's basically
about the distortive effect of stock
options on the economy in ways that we
don't see
you know just as a for instance you know
I mean I get a dollar of profit at my
company and I use it to grow there to
grow the business yeah I have business I
started with $500 I every dollar that
came in was from selling something to
somebody who wanted it you know it's a
old-fashioned company yeah we you know
it's it's that it's the Adam Smith
economy now you look at a lot of these
Silicon Valley companies they're
basically giant bets you know and and
it's interesting because they're not all
that way you know if you look at say
Google and you say okay I'm gonna just
sum up all of Google's profits and I'm
gonna say Larry and Sergey you're owners
of you know some particular share of
Google and you get to you know break in
your chips and take your share of their
retained earnings yeah they're still
worth you know 30 40 billion dollars
yeah because it's made a lot of money so
there's this bet and it paid off but now
look at Jeff Bezos that bet is still
running you know it's like the something
of Jeff had his share of all of Amazon's
accumulated profits you know he would
not be worth a hundred billion dollars
he's still you know because basically
you know if you look at you know
Amazon's price earnings ratio is
something like ten times Google's you
know and it's just like so this huge
financial bubble
and the thing is if we look at the real
estate values in San Francisco there's a
lot of money that's coming out of
nowhere every year these companies are
basically extracting vast amounts of
capital from people who are basically
playing the roulette game and that money
is flowing into the economy but it's a
very different kind of economy and I
think we need to understand that there's
a set of like of distortive factors in
our economy that lead to inequality and
that we're not all playing the same game
and again a lot of people in this room
are probably part of that Silicon Valley
economy but when we look at the rest of
the country and we wonder why they're so
mad at the
technology industry you know they're
looking at us in the same way that we
look back at that Wall Street which was
doing they had a funny money making
machine where they could basically crank
out their own special kind of money
called CEOs we have a special kind of
money called you know stock options in
these you know speculative companies and
it's this sort of creator of enormous
wealth but it's paper wealth and people
are able to cash that out and raise it
then it drives real estate prices it
drives everything you know it's not
actually necessarily again back to maps
there's a map of the economy well we
don't want people in this community
don't understand how incredibly
fortunate they are to be at this
particular time when a lot of people are
betting on the things that they're doing
and it's kind of interesting because of
course all the the cryptocurrency
speculation is really making super clear
just how bubblicious it is so one last
question for me and then we'll get to
your questions you know when you're
talking about this and at the lower
levels of this you said we think in
labels so it's it's it's interesting and
and for I think it's important for folks
who haven't read the book or may not
know having kind of cast off the labels
if I understand correctly to understand
better what's going on you brought
labels back to certain moments in time
and so open-source web 2.0 and the maker
movement are all three examples of
putting putting a label put in
collecting a moment into something you
know what are your thoughts about I
guess the power of doing that if they
were called something different would we
have a different future if they hadn't
been named at that time how do you how
do you think about the power and the
importance of putting a name well the
label is just shorthand and and so it's
sort of interesting because boobs both
open-source and web 2.0 in the maker
movement I actually didn't coin in any
of those terms open-source was coined by
Christine Peterson of the force
I'd Institute which is a nanotechnology
think-tank Dale Dougherty Corning web
2.0 and the maker movement dales now the
CEO of maker media but work with for me
and with me for many many years so I
basically laid out kind of a map of the
world and then and brought the right
people into the room and then the name
arrived you know the right name arrived
that caught the zeitgeist and you know
but but again the the label is you know
one level of the map but it's not the
you know it's like if the map you know
there were a lot of people heard web 2.0
and they kind of made it mean something
else
and I go well the words do tend to run
off with themselves don't they all right
we've got a question in the back start
us off hey there Jim
I'm curious to hear your thoughts on
society's ability to respond and handle
and adapt to the increasing rate of
change of technology or of the map it
you know it seems like it takes time for
people to get comfortable with any
change and we're just increasing the
pace of change and yeah challenge you on
that okay you know you hear that a lot
that the pace of change is faster but I
was looking recently at the distance
between the first you know mechanical
weaving machines you know the spinning
jenny and the fully integrated textile
mills of the 1840s it's about 80 years
and then you look at what's the dis how
far are we from the first digital
computers seventy years you know it's
like we think it's going faster it's not
going faster you know it really isn't
you know and I certainly you know look
back and you kind of imagine you know
the world of you know 1900 and the world
of 1950 and the world of 1950 and the
world of 2000 and I guarantee
you that the world of 1900 and 1950 so a
lot more change than the world of 1950
to 2000 or 1972 now I just think it's
just it's you know we're patting
ourselves on the back and we're giving
ourselves a pass for being such shitty
responders to you know the challenges of
our time and all right right there and
ok you know so I'm gonna retired early
childhood educator and I love the maker
movement I love maker IDI
I've been a hands-on play based teacher
for over 30 years and I was just
querying about what this next generation
and now the maker
edie movements been going on for what
over a decade or so along with some
early pioneers doing the hands-on play
based learning what is this generation
that's growing up with this kind of
learning opportunity what are we looking
at in the future with them I'm totally
energy energized about it you know I I
am too and I think III do think that
they you know it's not just maker head
it's just project based it's I think
what John Seely Brown and John Hagel
described as the power of pull is a huge
you know factor I mean just the ability
to have learning on demand I mean it's
really what my company does on the
professional side but you look at it
YouTube you know I mean I was talking
with Hal Varian Google's chief economist
about that this morning it's like the
number of how-to videos it's totally
possible for people to say I need to
know how to do something you know we're
moving toward that world it's a little
bit like The Matrix where a Trinity says
I need to know how to fly a helicopter
yeah yeah I remember that but you know
and there's this whole other side again
one of the things that I see that's such
an important way to think about the
future of learning is that we actually
have interfaces that teach you know you
think about you know one of the things
one of the things I do and I was gonna
spend some time I spent a lot of time in
the book unpacking uber and lyft in to
here's all the things that I see in
there I see
method workers I see the you know
managed by algorithm I see this network
platform the thing about this augmented
worker part of it
you can have this much greater supply of
drivers because they don't have to know
anything the app knows it they know how
to drive know how to drive but you know
it used to be that took time you know
the knowledge of the streets and
monuments of London is one of the most
difficult exams in the world you know it
takes three four five years to masters
like becoming a brain surgeon for
Christ's sake
you know you literally become it for
those of you who are fans of Dune you
become a mint at GPS you know yourself
the test is you know get from this
random point in London to that random
point in London and you give
turn-by-turn directions you know it's
like that's a you know the brains of
London taxi cab drivers used to change
you know now it's just like you follow
what the app tells you to do right and
that actually is this incredible
cognitive augmentation I think is the
next stage and when we see it with kids
my stepdaughter
you know just we had the experience that
I recount in the book where we were
having a fancy dinner for a donor for my
wife's nonprofit Code for America and
her daughter was 13 at the time said
what can I make dessert and we were like
well I guess you don't want to say no
but you're a little bit oh my god this
is gonna be you know a kid dessert you
know and it could be a disaster and
income something that you would be
amazed at getting at in a high-end
restaurant is these the eggshell thin
dark chocolate cups with ice cream and
fruit and that was beautiful and we're
like whoa where did you get it as well
you know III think she saw it on
Instagram and then she followed it got a
YouTube video and it was like you blow
up a balloon and you formed the
chocolate on that on the balloon you
have to wash the balloon first you know
she's kind of had it all down but it was
just like she just taught herself on the
fly to do this cool thing that she saw
and that's like what you know we need to
teach kids and we need to give everybody
the opportunity to do that on demand
learning then of course was at the heart
my business you know in building that
you know the Internet it was like we
produced that kind of content where
people go oh I want to build a website
well how do you do that well you they
would pull in the knowledge it used to
be books and now it's videos and yeah
but there's so much now that it's
learning on demand and knowing that you
can learn virtually anything and then we
have to figure out well what are the
fundamentals that will allow somebody to
get good at that and to have the
confidence to do that and then what are
the fundamental structural things that
will help them to you know use
particularly as you get into more
advanced areas to be able to really grok
it yeah
thanks Tim I you mentioned with respect
to micro biomes something to the effect
that if the marketplace is out of whack
the organization the organism won't live
up to its potential yeah how where are
today's internet companies out of whack
well the thing that I'm most concerned
about is that there seems to be a
pattern which is and I think it's really
driven by what I see as the master
algorithm of our economy which is you
must keep growing you know for the
financial markets basically the premium
is growth and so no matter how
idealistic you are if you're a public
company at some point you have to keep
growing because you pay your employees
largely in stock there's this hidden
flow you know which you yo see Mark
Zuckerberg and Larry and Sergey have
super voting stock oh they have control
but no they don't because guess what as
soon as their growth slows they can't
hire the best people anymore right
because those people expect that stock
that keep going up and so there's this
master algorithm in a financialized
economy which says you must grow and so
what these companies do they reach a
natural plateau and they can't just go
on and go out we're delivering this
great service you know let's just keep
doing it no they have to start eating
their ecosystem and that's what
do that's what Microsoft did it's what I
see Google doing one of the things that
I've been kind of noodling on I haven't
got to the bottom of because there may
be other reasons for but I noticed in
Google's financial statements that five
years ago thirty percent of their ad
revenue came from other people's sites
flat in 2016 it was down to eighteen
percent you know so because they're
offering more and more of the content
they used to come from other peoples on
the web directly in their own apps and I
go well you know that may be better for
users but it doesn't speak well for the
long-term health of the ecosystem of the
web and when that goes you know yeah
doing you know just that does that you
know you know the whole thing fall down
for Google just as it or at least slow
down and so this is kind of an argument
that I really try to make in the book
from tech and the lessons of say
Microsoft you're taking too much Google
maybe taking too much Facebook taking
too much go well guess what look at our
wider economy you know it's become
extractive and this is phase in
economies where they're very inclusive
and there's a lot of opportunity for
everyone and then at some point they
become extractive and as they become
extractive they lose their vitality and
of course this is the subject of Dharana
Acemoglu and James Robinson's book how
nations fail he talks about it in a
macroeconomic perspective so well Regas
the next question you one of the fun in
addition to poetry in this book there's
some sci-fi and you just mentioned dune
in passing so I've got a draw out for a
second as for folks that don't know your
first book was a book about and and
collaborating with well there's three
separate books I ran out of college I
got asked to write a book about Frank
Herbert they're also doing for a
collection of critical essays it was a
series of short monographs about science
fiction of detective authors and I got
to know Frank and in the course of it I
did a number of
use of them and then I pitched the idea
of a book of his essays and interviews
which I basically co-authored with him
and and that book is now up on do you
put the book up now is that when you put
up yeah the first one not the second one
the second one was a collection of
essays and interviews that was called
the maker of dune the first one is just
called Frank Herbert and it was
published by a small publisher that
eventually kind of got subsumed by
someone else and I tried to get back the
rights because it's no longer available
except on you know eBay or whatever and
there was nobody to be found this is the
the Google orphan works issue if you
ever followed what happened with and I
eventually said well screw it I'm gonna
put it up and I have a little disclaimer
that says if you know you ever want a
little bit like you ever see Kill Bill
you know it's like you know what if you
grow up you yeah you know where to find
me so I was like okay you know Frederick
Unger if anybody who owns those rights
ever you know you know wants to come
complain that I put it up for free you
know where to find me but you know 10 or
15 years on no one showed up so it's
available for free yeah so so it's a Rio
media.com slash Tim and Melinda calm is
in my personal archive and that's where
the science fiction okay you know what's
your what would you say the science
fiction perspective we're big believers
here that science fiction is not just
fun it's telling us something about the
future how do you think about a science
fiction thought and and has it is it
something that you kind of apply or did
you learn anything from Frank Herbert
what would you say about the science
fiction viewpoint and the real world
well I guess I would just say that in
general the thing I probably took more
from science fiction from anyone else
than anything else was this idea that
you could be a nerd and you could change
the world and you know a hero you know
it's like yeah yeah you know it's funny
because actually that was the thing I
love the most about Star Wars but I
when George Lucas understood the soul of
science fiction at least as I experience
it like here you are you this kid in
this you know back-ass place you know
and you kind of think that there must be
more to the world and that you can make
a difference and sure enough it happens
you know under the court you think about
Heine lines have space suit will travel
or you know just all of those it's just
some opportunity to you know make a
difference and that to me science
fiction is this sense of hope and
possibility and capability and the
ability that we have to grow into that
capability at both as individuals and as
a species and another one in the back
there
heightened so I was wondering what you
thought the role of government is in
driving future innovation whether that
be in initial investment in new
technologies or in setting up good
infrastructure or tech innovation to
take place or in general education I
would just say in general one of the
most serious bad maps that's out there
right now is that government you know is
this bad thing that's bad for the
economy what the business you know just
you know go off and do its thing you
know I remember when Barack Obama said
you know you didn't build that and
everybody gave him a hard time you know
no look around you know I didn't build
that road you know I didn't you know
make sure that everybody in the country
had power and telecommunications you
know as opposed to only a few I didn't
you know there's all these things that
we built and there's a wonderful book
that I highly recommend called the
entrepreneurial state by Mariana
Masakazu which basically you know
explodes that myth it kind of looks for
example an iPhone and describes the you
know 20 or 30 key technologies that were
funded by the government that made the
iPhone possible everything from a fast
Fourier transform oh it's just like this
yeah for a signal processing it's just
like basic stuff you know GPS you know
the Internet you know the
a bunch of the chips there's just so
much of this stuff was there lying
around for the taking because somebody
invested in it and and and I think a lot
of what you know thing about you know
what's happened with the genome you know
the Human Genome Project and and you
know we're now you know anyway I think
the government investment you know in
common infrastructure is incredibly
important and actually the thing that's
really the probably the biggest problem
with government is it needs reinvention
and it's very hard to reinvent it yeah I
mean I the thing that's really good
about markets is that the competition
does force reinvention and when you have
a monopoly on certain kinds of power
it's very hard to be reinvented but it
does happen and is there's a you know
I'm very involved with that sort of
government reinvention movement I was
just talking with Peter Schwartz today
he was telling me about the finance
minister of New South Wales Australia
who's just going all in on you know
government reinvention and sounds like
doing him incredible work and of course
the work that my wife does it code for
America working with a bunch of states
on reinventing government programs is
incredibly effective and making good
things happen so and mariano marcado
spoke for us in the seminar series so
you can find on long now.org you can
find her talk which is great as an
entree to to her work we also had a
speaker here in this series named Louis
Hyman and that videos on the interval
website also on our podcast both of them
and he looked at the New Deal and how
the government during the time of the
New Deal invested in technology and
helped to make those those things there
so so both of those are are useful
vectors on that that important topic so
it's interesting so the book I think I
counted 14 speakers in all between are
the interval series and the seminar
series that are at least reference and
your book several board members and and
founders of this organization as well
and of course you've got to seminar
speakers in your family so with with
with Jenna and Saul your son-in-law so
yeah at the end of towards the end of
the book one of your sort of summing up
points you actually talk about the very
first long now seminar which was the
Brian Eno talk just just in the other
building right here on Fort Mason I
wonder as a faith as a favorite as what
can you recall anything about that
evening do you remember or do you
remember how the the idea of the long
now because he articulates it's it's a
talk about the big here in the long now
yes I mean I stole shamelessly from his
talk I'm sure that the Stuart remembers
it far better than I do but yeah I don't
have anything particularly to add other
than that again it was that wonderful
you know notion the the story how many
of you have know the story of house
along now actually so I read it sure
since I've got it in here somewhere I
probably have it bookmarks I don't have
a bookmark but I'll find it by looking
in this cleverest here we go an index
its 355 I I love that so the musician
Brian Eno tells the story about the
experience that led him to conceive of
the ideas that evolved into the long now
foundation a group that works to
encourage long term thinking in 1978
Brian was invited to a rich
acquaintances housewarming party and as
the neighborhood his cab drove through
became dingier and dingy er he began to
wonder if he was in the right place
quote finally the cab driver stopped at
the doorway of the gloomy unwelcoming
industrial building he writes to winos
were crumpled on the steps oblivious
there was no other sign of life in the
whole street but he was at the right
address and when he stepped out on the
top floor he just got
a multi-million dollar palace I just
didn't understand the explains why would
anyone spend so much money building a
place like that in a neighborhood like
this later I got into conversation with
the hostess do you like it here
I asked it's the best place I've ever
lived she replied but I mean you know is
it an interesting neighborhood oh the
neighborhood
well that's outside she laughed in the
talk many years ago where I first heard
him tell this story Brian went on to
describe the friends apartment the space
she controlled as the small here and the
space outside full of winos and
derelicts as the big here he went on
from there along with others to come up
with the analogous concept of the long
now we need to think about the long now
and the big here or one day our society
will enjoy neither so I guess I would
just say I have an enormous debt to this
intellectual tradition I think Stewart
knows this the rest of you don't when I
was you know you know in college you
know I desperately wanted to be
published in in coevolution quarterly
and I sent off numerous pieces I
actually had one accepted but never
published but it was the first place
that I looked to you know was sort of
aspirational for me to be you know part
of this world so I was always really
glad when I eventually got to be part of
this world well that is why I'm just you
know I am very grateful to Stuart and
Lawrence and you know all of you built
this kind of intellectual heritage it
really is a real gift to the world thank
you
so I know there are a lot more questions
you're gonna stick around you're gonna
be signing books but please you can get
books in the back you can come up here
get your book sign or talk with Tim and
please stick around and and keep the
conversation going Tim I have a long now
challenge coin thank you for awesome for
for speaking and just really great
really enjoyed the book and thank you
everybody please stick around skip one
more big round of applause for doing
[Applause]
[Music]